pour s'assurer de l'inocuité de
plusieurs produits injectables comme les
vaccins contre la copie 19 l'industrie
pharmaceutique utilise un test à base de
sang de lits mule
cela met beaucoup de pression sur cette
espèce très ancien dont l'existence
pourraient maintenant être menacée
en anglais on l'appelle chouchou crade
mais ce n'est pas un crâne la limule
appartient à la famille des arts henning
cette créature est apparue sur terre il
y à plus de 400 millions d'années bien
avant les dinosaures
difficile d'imaginer qu'aujourd'hui cet
animal étrange permet de sauver des
millions de vies c'est quand pleinement
démis son rôle pour assurer la sécurité
des vaccins est devenu crucial
mais la pression sur cette espèce est
tellement forte qu'on craint maintenant
pour sa survie
maintenant
[Musique]
la limule est un animal plutôt mal aimé
que connaît bien le professeur
d'océanographie jean éric tremblay vous
comprendrez que son apparence joue pas
pour elle et aussi du fait que c'est un
animal qui a survécu pendant très
longtemps on pense qu'elle peut résister
à tout donc on a peut-être tendance à
pas s'en soucier au tac on devrait en
asie les populations de l'imu leçons
sérieusement menacé c'est qu'en plus
d'être servi un repas leur habitat ne
cesse de se dégrader sur la côte
atlantique des etats-unis
l'espèce est considérée comme étant
vulnérables
75 % des stocks historiques de limur
auraient disparu la population est
beaucoup moins nombreuse qu'elle l'était
son conséquence de tout l'accumulation
de l'exploitation qu'on a fait au fil du
stage chez nos voisins du sud
les limouxins ont d'abord été prélevés
par millions pour servir de fertilisants
agricoles
aujourd'hui la pêche commerciale
constitue la principale cause de
mortalité de l'espèce près d'un million
de l'immeuble sont capturées
annuellement et servent d'appât pour
d'autres espèces plus lucratives
mais en ces temps difficiles une forme
d'exploitation de la limule inquiète
particulièrement celle de son
utilisation en pharmacie c'est que la
limule a un sens bien particulier d'un
sang bleu aux propriétés immunitaire
incomparable c'est un sens qui est très
particulier la limule en fait
contrairement à nous on a des globules
rouges et des globules blancs a un sens
qu'on appelle de l'hémolymphe donc c'est
un fluide qui est quand même un peu
différent et qui ne contient pas de
globules blancs
pour les protéger des attaques externes
l'évolution a plutôt de télé limule d'un
sens qui contient des cellules
spécialisées qu'on appelle les âmes est
possible lorsque ces cellules entre en
contact avec des bactéries elles
provoquent une réaction de coagulation
c'est pas la bactérie en tant que tel
qui est nocif c'est ce qu'on appelle les
endotoxines qui sont sécrétées par la
bactérie eceh
pour justement empêcher ces endotoxines
là de se propager dans l'animal que
cette réaction là va se produire au
milieu du xxème siècle des chercheurs
qui ont étudié les des mules ont compris
qu'elle pourrait peut-être nous venir en
aide
on s'est posé la question est ce qu'on
peut utiliser les propriétés spéciales
sans de la limule comme test comme
diagnostic pour détecter la présence de
substances bactérienne donc besoin d'eau
toxique dans différents médicaments
différents vaccins
les recherches ont mené au développement
du test à base de l'isad à mes beaux
sites de limur le test la halle approuvé
officiellement en 1977 le test la halle
est devenu la référence sur la planète
pour assurer l'innocuité des médicaments
des vaccins et des appareils qui entre
en contact avec le sang humain
chaque année aux états unis près de
500000 limule sont capturés pour servir
à la fabrication du test la halle celi
mules sont transportés dans des
laboratoires où on prélève près du tiers
de leur sang avant de les retourner
vivant à l'océan
le problème c'est que selon certaines
études de 15 à 30 % d'entre elles
meurent durant le processus
[Musique]
aujourd'hui en pleine pandémie de kobe
la demande pour le test à base de 100
devis bulle explose
le test la halle est utilisé dans toute
la chaîne de production des vaccins on
sait en ce moment avec la crise
sanitaire que la production de vaccins à
l'échelle mondiale va avoir augmenté de
façon très significatif
le biologiste américain larry mize a
consacré sa carrière à la préservation
des lits mule de la paix du delaware
il est préoccupé en ces temps de
pandémie en raison de la pj de 19
la demande pour le sens de l'imu il va
monter en flèche cela entraînera une
augmentation significative de la
mortalité des les mules larina crois que
si la baisse des populations de limeuil
se poursuit les conséquences seront
dramatiques c'est que les eaux de
limeuil sont très riches en lipides et
sont essentielles à la survie des
poissons mais aussi à celles de
plusieurs oiseaux migrateurs dont
certains sont considérés en voie de
disparition
devant ce constat on peut s'interroger
sur ce qui doit être privilégié la
survie des mules ou la santé des yeux
[Musique]
c'est un faux choix
nous ne devrions pas dépendre uniquement
d'une espèce qui a du mal à survivre
c'est ça l'argument principal une
solution pour sortir de cette dépendance
au lit mule a peut-être été trouvé au
fil du temps on a réussi à avec le
produit progrès de la génétique a
identifié le gène chez elle à limeuil en
fait qui est responsable de la
production de ces fameux facteurs
chimiques qui sont contenus dans les
amibes au site
cette perle rare qui permet de détecter
les endotoxines c'est le facteur c des
entreprises bio médical s'en servent
désormais pour produire un test
synthétique
le rfc un procédé qu'il fait plus appel
aux sens des limites
ce nouveau test à partir du facteur sert
combinant deux lits mule a été autorisé
en europe en 2016
mais aux états unis on ne permet
toujours pas son utilisation à grande
échelle la pandémie actuelle nous oblige
à repenser l'utilisation du test la
halle à base de sang de limur l'heure
des choix et peut-être arriver on dépend
de la survie de la limule dans le fond
pour le test haut la halle et la
possibilité d'avoir maintenant une
alternative de synthèse 20 pourrait nous
permettre en grande partie de
s'affranchir du du testo lane
[Musique]